it's
[Music]
try to
again
all right so the first thing is you're
going to clear the line so he has
MoDOT okay you don't don't go after the
fact don't go after you never you're not
going to get there you go if you catch
it after the fact you should have gone
this
way so it's in harmony with him W then
you need that angle of cancellation so
this elbow has to be in can't be
down that's what you're trying for and
then you clear the line so he's coming
he's coming in and you're going this way
okay
this way so he has to grab and you do
both boom
harmoniously boom boom
okay boom it's on your
Center I don't lift the sword just move
okay his energy is going to help me lift
it
okay let's
try okay so you see his energy lifts the
sword I don't I don't lift it okay then
I move underneath
it and think about what you want so you
have the Tilt you're working on that
body tilt on here okay so as you come
around that is all you want you don't
want to pull
him so he bends
this is all I want I'll take it as far
as I can and then from
there I will do the rest with my
base as I monitor how much I need and
can have to keep him here so what I
don't want to do is pull him down I
don't want to do
that I'm just kind of monitoring for the
tilt there I feel his resistance that's
all I get so I come
in and project with my hip so in the
same way I project with my hand I can
project with my
hip Bo up
he injected my hips it's not just
entering or he'll slide down your leg
he'll slide down
it I got to get rid of
him I'm projected my head long boom
tilt okay let's
try
so I know at the end my my B is going
over here but it's cuz he's falling and
then he lets go but you should be able
to tell that my arm is relaxed and it's
not cutting it down I think if you can't
tell that there's no tension in the body
you just haven't trained long enough to
you can't even tell that you got to be
able to tell that okay so there's a I'm
not pulling down on
him the first part that I have to get
him to get more tilt is that I'm come to
the
front is the the initial connection with
the elbow so when the sword goes up you
see what it's doing to his elbow if I
can get his elbow vertical then he'll
have more back to him you see do you
guys get that
so you can't you can't have that be dead
I am doing that but it's on it's on the
up so if I enter over here I won't be
able to affect the elbow here's his
elbow so on him right now I have to
enter there and as I lift the sword up I
make sure I keep that elbow going up and
so it goes backwards all right so here
come around
camera I'm not pulling anymore that's
about it from here here I know I can
project on that but I'm right at the
edge so it's not not holding them up not
forcing them down it's just right there
and then I
enter and he lets go my sword was being
pulled by
gravity you can watch my
grip
loose okay try it again